Hobbs and Shah is out and as of this
taping is fresh and 72% with the critics
overall agreeing that if you know you're
in for it delivers is this another case
of soap ad it's good or is it actually
good let's find out
hi everyone I'm Mark Ellis and welcome
back to the after show this is a spoiler
heavy show so if you've not yet seen
Hobson sha you have been warned and I am
thrilled to be joined by an all-star
group of panelists here today first up
she is film correspondent Niki Novak hi
I am so excited yes I'm very excited
that's right and then also making his
debut he's a film critic for The Wrap in
the LA Times Carlos Aguilar how are you
bud thank you excited to talk to them
some fun scenes about this movie yeah
this is this a fun movie to talk about
and our returning champion via Skype in
Atlanta you know her from payer weight
my buddy Sharada Williams is here how
are you sure Rhonda I am doing just
fantabulous today how are you I'm great
because we get to talk about Hobbs and
Shawn it's just a it's just a big dumb
fun action movie in my opinion so before
we actually get into our first topic
which we love when y'all come and chime
in on each one of our topics is this
movie fresh or is this movie rotten
Carl's me to start with you is it fresh
or rotten think is fresh if you know
that the ridiculous
kind of amount of madness you're in for
and you know if you appreciate the
banter between these two stars that
thing you have a good time I think
that's what makes it fresh
my vote is fresh is well so we got two
Oh Sharonda are you contributing to our
freshness of course this movie was
absolutely ridiculous of course it's
gonna be fresh okay Nikki you're the
last one I don't know what you're all
talking about cuz I think it should be
an award season contender thing it's a
fun pop group you're using fresh for me
too it is fresh for me too because I
love when when a movie advertises itself
like hey this is what you're getting
into right so I'm still like the kid
that was mowing everybody's lawn saving
up money to go to the movies
this movie sold me on what it was and
what I got the most out of this movie
was the dual performances of the rock
and Jason Statham I thought they were so
much fun together I thought they were a
comedy gold the action was great so
Nikki want to start with you did the
Statham rock combination live up to the
hype for you
I think it did and I think look I don't
think they would have a spin-off even
though they have huge star power I don't
think I think they knew it was gonna
work and I think we all kind of knew
what was gonna work and I mean I love
the two of them but what I really loved
was the addition of Vanessa Kirby
because I kind of felt like it was a
trio through most of the movie and I
thought she really I would never say she
out Shaun them because they're both huge
stars in their own right but for me to
sort of jump into that universe and sort
of go toe-to-toe and there was a scene
in the beginning where she in the rocker
sort of going across the table at each
other and I was just like damn yeah it
was fun watching I don't have fight
scenes with them yes because I agree
with Nikki I think that for the bulk of
this movie you are following a trio and
it's fun to watch each one of them so
it's maybe not a two star movie right I
mean I think that the animosity between
them is really exciting especially you
know I recall the scene in the airplane
so this kind of confined space in which
they can really you know punch each
other but the tensions there and then
you add the cameos you know that are
kind of very uh star heavy and it makes
for such a joyful you know hate love
relationship between the two of them
yeah Sharonda i would agree with the
panel's here on the couch are you as big
a fan of the rock and Jason Statham's
chemistry as we are um yes I really love
their chemistry together I still just
have certain feelings towards Jason
Statham's character cuz justice behind I
just have to say that right there but
outside of that they have great
chemistry after watched an entire
two-hour movie of them just insulting
each other back and forth and then how
do you feel about the fight scene
between the rock and Vanessa Kirby me
that was the because we see the
beginning the movie and it's fun and
then you see her go toe to toe toe to
toe with the rock and hold her own and
I'm like wow she really is delivering
she's living up to that Mission
Impossible hype yes I agree with Nikki I
really love what Vanessa Kirby brought
to this film and she really held her own
and I love how she really commanded the
attention and the scenes as she's not
only fighting you know doing Johnson but
also too I'm just throughout the entire
film and especially did a very fantastic
job and so then you added herself with
to the next Carlos and this is a guy who
clearly could have just mailed in a
performance and had a little bit of fun
with it I really got into his character
and I think I responded to it
more than I thought I would right I mean
he goes full you know mad scientist kind
of type of bill and right and I love the
fact that we don't really get you know
into the specifics of this organization
and the villains and the madness of it
always just him representing the evil
that's chasing them something that he
just goes for broke in this performance
yeah because it's a spoiler review I can
say this like Nicky at the end of the
movie when he's he's offloaded and I'm
like we can save him
we have Todd we can it's emotional yeah
I was like no for the next move we may
have to save this but I see him in the
next one for that very specific reason
oh we like go down and we like yes'm
yeah
archaeologically I don't know I think I
think so and I think it would be a
tremendous loss to have this character
just be a one movie kind of thing
because he actually what I loved about
it is in a lot of movies not superhero
movies not so much but in a lot of
action movies the villain doesn't
necessarily partake in the action
sometimes they're just sort of sitting
back giving orders well all the other
guys are doing it but the fact that he
was this cyber you know Terminator type
of person and I've seen him in a lot of
movies but I've never felt the presence
that I felt from him in this movie yeah
do you agree with that tape yeah I mean
he also he has this old vendetta you
know is there's like the emotional
component that he's is a villain that
has this master plan behind but he also
hates you since item character right so
he goes for him
shirani on the same page you want to see
more of our bio-genetically super
villain Idris Elba are you kidding me of
course I do he has so much swag the
entire family just like I know that he's
got on a bad side but if he is I don't
want to be right anymore he played a
great villain even from when I was first
introduced to him in the wire he just
always plays a very charismatic villain
alright so we're having a good time
talking about the movie so far and we
all like the performances here comes the
first real curveball the show Nikki I'm
gonna start with you does this movie
prove in a sort of an inverse way that
the rock is actually better when he has
a co-star to play off of because his
individual movies you take something
like a skyscraper or something like san
andreas rampage it's not quite as high
in the tomato meter as a central
intelligence or some of these other ones
he gets to team up with like Jumanji so
do you think that this is proof that the
needs a co-star to have a great film I
don't and I'll tell you why I actually
thought San Andreas really worked and
and they did really well at the box
office and I think it was one of those
movies one of those so bad it's good
movies were but where it really was an
enjoyable movie at the end of the day
you know Baywatch not so much but that
was an ensemble so you could argue you
know that was an ensemble Zac Efron and
those two together had great chemistry I
think it's more the storyline and the
this few misses that he's had
unfortunately kind of kind of haven't
been in a row so you feel it more than
if there had been a hit and then a miss
and then a hit but then he did have
Jumanji but no I think look I mean you
look at his following and what he's
really smart about doing is building his
international following and I think he's
what he's doing right now is delivering
what he thinks fans want and he he want
and he said that before so I think if he
keeps going down that route I'm gonna do
these you know action type films you're
gonna have some misses especially when
you're in an era where it's so hard if
you're not in a universe to establish a
you know a one-off well sure I mean if I
put you in in the lineage of Arnold
Schwarzenegger movies or Stallone movies
there's a lot of misses maybe argue
would be arguably more misses than hits
Sharonda if I drop you off in a movie
theater I say you can go see the rock
headline a movie by himself or you get
to go see him co-star with one of those
either action or comedy buddies which
theater you going into I mean personally
I'm going to go into the comedy door
however I think it's not fair to say
that he can't command a movie with just
themselves I do think that it's more of
an understanding what you're getting
yourself into
I think and the audience we tend to take
movie starring himself more seriously
than if we hear hacks and Shaw or
central intelligence I think we expect
to have this fun enjoyable right yeah
Carlos be on the same page would you
rather see him team up in more of a
comedic aspect I mean I think that
definitely works in this in this one you
know the banter between them is really
fun but he's a superstar you know I feel
like there's no doubt that when you see
his name on that billboard you want to
see it you know even if it's not hostile
even if it's not rampage or whatnot I
feel like he commands the attention of
the audience and you know I was at the
premiere for this movie and there was a
sort of like a moment in which there was
an incident with fire and they had to
stop the movie and he came out and kind
of like Kay
- like - no calm the ADI was this real
forest it's like hey and he came out on
like kind of like you know commanded the
audience and you know made of fun and
kind of brought everyone back to like
you know an enjoyable after the
stressful kind of moment he brought it
back so I think he's you know people
loved him and you know he could come and
sometimes made it better I almost
thought that they should have videoed
that and just had an intermission for
everybody watching it across the board
and just insert that because he did he
upped the ante and then he sort of like
nobody else I think could do that yeah I
mean the guy conquered the San Andreas
Fault earthquake gonna get pretty good
by firing a movie theater so the rock
and Jason Statham and Vanessa Kirby as
well or your headliners of the movie but
I think a lot of people Carlos are
responding to the cameos that we have we
had Ryan Reynolds we Kevin Hart I
thought I stole that entire airplane
scene did you enjoy the cameos do you
think they took away from the story
where are you with that oh I love them I
definitely prefer the Ryan Reynolds
character I thought he was incredibly
funny I like to think that that's a
memory alive really wanted to be the
Rock's best friend you know because it
feels just so earnest and fun and you
know wiling his kind of antics to become
his friend that you know the rock being
such a superstar I feel like there may
be many actors out there that want to be
his best friends yeah you Sharonda I'm
watching that scene play and I'm
thinking this is exactly what The Rock
and Kevin Hartz social media feud is
like and gods actually watch that
factored into the storyline a little bit
so I loved it the airplane thing I
literally yelled out loud I screamed
when I saw him in the first place I
loved that entire sequence and even with
Ryan Reynolds and what I will say is
after the first set of cameos when the
second round came in I was just like
yeah I'm kind of over it I was happy
with the first one I don't know if we
need it till I go into the second one it
made me feel more as though they're
going to introduce the characters into
this house and shark franchise yeah so
I'll give Rob Delaney a shout out to
because he also makes a fun cameo Nikki
which of the cameos do you think enhance
the film Kevin was my favorite I always
loved Ryan Reynolds but I felt like Ryan
Reynolds was doing Ryan Reynolds not
that Kevin wasn't but I felt like there
was a couple moments that Ryan's
there was a few lines that I was like Oh
Ryan's like really like pushing almost a
little bit we just have that great
Deadpool rapport so yeah I felt that but
I think that Kevin Hart was such a
surprise and I just I've now seen this
movie three times and I saw it the first
time by myself the second time at the
premiere in the third time with a lot of
millennial influencers so it's three
totally different responses but I will
say in the premiere I'm sure you felt
the same thing when Kevin's face first
appeared on screen it the place erupted
totally erupted with with Ryan I think
it was cuz it was towards the beginning
it was more like oh wow like it was more
surprised but I think Kevin really knew
I actually wanted to see one more scene
with Kevin in the end I wanted him to
come in and save the day me and I wanted
him to be the sort of person that came
through with like a key thing in the end
that sort of helped get a phone a
helicopter something like that and some
oh there's there's one other is sort of
maybe kind of cameo there's at least
rumor that we'll talk about later on in
the show but right now I want to get to
the meat of Hobson shot which is those
incredible action set-pieces like i said
david leitch is a director here at
Carlos and you know he knows how to pull
off action very well both close
hand-to-hand combat then also like these
big giant you you know it's just getting
crazier and crazier every movie so did
the action live up to the hype for you
of course yeah the scenes are so
ridiculous you know you have to you know
commit to this disbelief right that
nothing in this world functions like
reality they're almost like superheroes
at this point the kind of stunts they
pull so that that final sequence with
the trucks and the helicopter in Samoa
is just so off the chain that you know
watching in a big screen with a crowd of
people is just such a an emotional
experience in a way that you know
watching our lonely probably wouldn't
work but on a theatre with that level of
action it's just so much fun they're
poor helicopter Niki Ryan I think by the
way that wasn't CGI the rock actually
did that are the best tours in the
business they get their teens exactly
connected to the drug do you think that
this was the best action that we've seen
in a fast and furious or fast and
furious movie I wouldn't say it was the
best I see for me it was sort of a
two-parter sort of it some of it felt
like that sort of close up the slo-moes
felt very David Leitch it felt very
atomic blond or you know what he's done
in the past
and then the sort of big action set
pieces like the helicopter and that felt
very fast and furious to me so they felt
like two different things and very two
different elements in terms of like the
big action if it wasn't for the last
helicopter bit and that rock because
that's what I love about fast and
furious
I want to suspend my just you know
belief and and I want to enjoy those
moments that you could never it's almost
superhero ask it really the way in a way
but I felt like David Leitch what did
what he does really well and I love
those sort of close up and I love the
two three-way fights that we've had
because I don't think we've seen that
before in cinema and I think it just
really pulled that off as well so you
said something very interesting and sure
I want to get your take on this so it's
kind of like these blockbuster movies
are becoming more and more superhero
films so it's almost like you can
incorporate them into the MCU seamlessly
Sharonda do you like this trend that
it's becoming more like a Marvel movie
every time you go see one of these
blockbusters particularly a fast and
furious movie where these they used to
they're gonna stream razors back when I
was a kid they're just living their
lives the corner mile at a time and
super enough sand Honda Civics and now
they're literally stopping genetically
engineered viruses that are perpetrated
by super bad guys are you a fan of this
trend with the Fast and Furious films I
definitely am I think I mean there's
been so many movies you have to start
evolving you have to start introducing
these new even more ridiculous and crazy
concepts into the film I mean the rock
literally jumps out of ability and like
scales of building down a road but you
should not have a hand
you shouldn't have our arm but it was
cool watching them do it I love the
action in it I don't think that it fully
lives up to the absurdity of The Fast
and Furious movies I think I've seen
better more crazier unrealistic things
happen but I had a great time watching
it
yeah they're gonna see the the the the
car is going out of the airplane again
anytime soon that's pretty cry I would
not parachute with a car friendly
helpful it's it for all you kids at home
all right Carl it's your favorite action
scene in this movie which one did you
dig the best I think it is that one by
far and I mean when I talk about the one
in semo I mean the beginning with the
kind of like combat with the old-school
weapons I love that I think that's very
interesting and sort of like brings it
back down to you know not using guns and
kind of like the
so the beginning of that and then going
into the trucks and the airplane and you
know so like this big finale and thing
just brings it home because he has a
cultural element as well you know which
you think elevates the franchise yeah I
like the the final little fistfight that
we had at the waterfall just because it
was you know it was a little on the nose
but it's like hey Hobbs and Shaw they
finally realized if they work together
they're gonna be able to do and that's
the only way they're gonna be able to
defeat this villain the only real
complaint I've heard about any of the
action is that it started to drag the
film down a little bit does anybody feel
that way that maybe we could've used a
little less action I actually felt like
I know the movies very long and and
that's a critique that I've heard that
it's 2 hours and 15 minutes I could have
been shorter there wasn't anything I
disliked about it there wasn't anything
that other than I think that sort of
opening sequence before you see them
side by side in the morning getting
their coffee and their very different
ways of getting ready for work there was
sort of a sequence where they both sort
of go after like where's the virus and
they fight a bad guy and you know the
rock tattoos the thing on the guy's head
and and I felt like you didn't need that
I felt that whole sequence you didn't
need I think you could have set it up
almost started the film off with the
side-by-side of them getting ready I
don't think you needed that whole bit
because it didn't really add anything to
the film and I feel like the two big
sort of second and third acts set pieces
were enough Sharona you agree with that
do you think we could have lost that
little breakfast slash gym montage at
the beginning or what what part of the
film felt the most out of place to you
because it just establishes how
different they are but for me while
watching the film I literally thought
the movie ended three different times in
this lake I was like okay it's about the
end let me get my stuff together I was
like no there's like a whole nother set
piece that we have to go through so for
those moments it did drag for me it
wasn't necessarily um it had too much
action it was just a little bit too much
going on from like a storyline I felt as
though they were trying to check all of
the beats of what a fast and furious
movie is we have to have family we have
to have conflicts and just I don't I
just think that they had a little bit
too many ideas with Hobbs and Shawn that
could have been left on the cutting room
floor Carlos do you think we could have
trimmed some some of the fat off this
movie maybe a little bit you know I go
back to the scene you know the Mexico
nitrous Lisa Gonzalez is in the film for
like one second and I feel like either
you know they could have chosen to use
her character more or cut it out
entirely you know because it just feels
like Jesus introduced briefly very
quickly even though she isn't the poster
and she's kind of like you know being
you know hell as part of the movie she's
very you know for a brief moment in the
film so either for me was either cut at
or expand that character that's a great
point she was like the captain phasma
this movie where it's like you're on a
lot of the artwork and then it's like
you showed up in goodbye I personally
like the breakfast montage just because
that's two different ways of waking up
than I'm used to I'm yeah no that's a
part I wish they kept in I wish that was
the opening scene of the movie and cut
out the action yeah yeah I mean I'm not
doing what the rock does I'm not waking
up at 6:00 a.m.
mine would be like 10:30 a.m. and I'm
not going to the gym and I'm not making
myself a frittata I'm just sitting in
line at Starbucks like the rest of us so
I I have some work to do before I look
like the rock or Jason Statham or decide
to save the world so our last topic here
today is a question more about the
future of fast and furious or fast and
furious presents and srong I want to go
to you first on this is this the way
that you would like to see the Hobbes
and Shaw characters continue their
adventures do you want this to stay away
from the main franchise because there's
just little winks and nods and that's
really it this really felt like it's
it's own film yeah definitely think that
it should stay separate
and I think the only way that they can
really bring this together is to really
handle the whole justice for Han yes I
am gonna bring that up again because
it's very important to me but I do think
that it needs to stay separate but I do
think that even has a shot has a lot of
spin-offs potential I want to see a
movie with Helen Mirren just basically
telling her kids like what they need to
help her steal Nicks
I think that there's so many characters
that they introduced into this franchise
that I want to see an expand I want to
see more not only of just them but the
people that they were kind of in contact
with as well yeah Nikki do you think
that uh then Diesel's get a little
nervous like we got this this whole
other spin-off franchise that maybe
doesn't need to be incorporated into
future fast and furious he's just fine I
think he's doing just fine I think you
know they're keeping things very
separate they've sort of made their mark
here what I find what
like about this is they've gone in sort
of many different directions with this
film it felt a little mission impossible
it felt a little fast and furious it
felt a little old-school buddy cop so I
feel like they can sort of hone in on
what really worked and it can really go
in any direction and you think about the
fast franchise how it evolved I'd like
to see them go moral to over the top of
cameos more over the top with their
relationship even the family stuff with
the rock I don't think was explored
enough I think a second solids could
even come back there's potential
potential for a Juris so there's a lot
of different ways they can go and
hopefully they'll go in the right one
yeah and Carlos I think you made the
point earlier that it felt like maybe
some of the individual scenes felt
different than a normal fast and furious
movie partially because it is director
David Lee Chan and like you said your
cameos he's got Ryan Reynolds is it Rob
Delaney pops in from Deadpool 2 and when
you look at this is that how you like
the film's to continue or do you want to
see them just take this and the events
of this movie and match them right into
the next Fast and Furious though I think
they're gonna probably expand this
universe on its own a little bit kind of
like what Marvel did with each of the
characters and then bring it back
together for an adventurous type of film
with all the Fast and Furious characters
and the ones that they've introduced
here so to me that's probably where the
French is going to you know make a
couple more movies in this franchise
maybe develop another one with another
character and then bring them all
together okay so you want to see them
spin this off a little bit further right
then maybe have a giant like Avengers
infinity war and they're reuniting of
everything Sharonda where do you want to
see the Hobbes and Shaw franchise go
from here I just wanted to see it expand
bigger and bigger I want to definitely
see more women I thought they did a very
great job absolute venison Kirby's
character just to see that expand and
not just be a damsel in distress
situation which they didn't do in this
movie but I do want to see them
introduce more characters and I would
love to see like this big you know just
finale with everyone and email them to
the previous can we get somebody Tokyo
your people even so just like pop back
in as well I'll be very happy to see
that too so there's so justice for Tokyo
Drift now Nicky I'm gonna give you a car
watch I got you we got the Fast and
Furious movies we have the spin-off with
Hobson Shaw
any other franchises that you want to
see the mixed into this world and
cookie batter as we progress down this
blockbuster combination film route to be
mixed in with a fast and furious sure
I'll give you something as easy as a as
maybe a John wick or something on that
order gave me an easy answer because I
think there was some Keanu Reeves rumors
that he was going to be in this film
david leitch continues to direct there's
no reason why he couldn't that was you
just gave me my answer basically well
good because it also sets up our next
little point here is that there's a lot
of rumors going around that voice that
we hear that is helping you know control
everything and giving Andrus his kind of
marching orders is actually the voice of
Charlize Theron who was cypher in Fast
and Furious 8 now I heard a
contradicting report from somebody was
all very early test screening that in
fact that voice was done by Keanu Reeves
that's what I heard too yeah really hope
and I hate saying this but I did not
love this Charlize character so I'm
hoping it's not I don't know I just it
just didn't work for me I thought like
it I don't know she just didn't fit into
the franchise to me and the performance
just didn't compel me to want to see
more okay so we'll keep her buried as
far as Nikki goes girls wait what do you
hope the fallout is from the voice like
what is gonna happen with the voice I
mean I think it would make sense for it
to be Charlie's if they want to blend
these two franchises right the rather
than introduced can arrives we do make
sense also because of the director but
if you wanna kind of like a seamless or
at least you know you know claim that
you had a connection always from the
beginning it should be
Charlie's then you know it wouldn't
surprise me that's the case okay sure
honor we've given you two great
nominations for where the boys could go
who is doing the voice what is your
ideal voice scenario I mean I'm gonna go
for can Therese be Fez Charlie's she's
very capable but they really if they
bring her back they really need to give
her more to do make her a more
convincing villain okay well as we close
up shop here I do need to go around the
horn really quick and just ask you all
your favorite Fast & Furious films Ron
I'm gonna start with you you're you you
can throw Tokyo Drift at me if you want
I have not seen Tokyo Drift think that's
the one that I've not seen yet so I
apologize in advance what is the best
Fast & Furious
I mean first into middle reason I have
to go with like Fast & Furious 7 if I
want to say the one that like really
brought the whole franchise back it will
be 5 yeah absolutely 5 I'm still going
to fast 5 I think that was the best of
the little street racing movies that we
knew and these huge giant world-saving
blockbusters I like that that was the
best combo of the two Carlos which where
are you going I think I'll go with the
first one I think it was such a landmark
kind of film in terms of you introducing
this concept that you know who would
have thought that 20 years later will be
still talking about it so I feel like
the first one you know set up the the
groundwork for a film you know for car
fans or in action fans and then develop
into something huge so I'll go the first
one it all goes back to that first film
Nick you have a buddy who got married
and in his wedding vows included fast
and furious quotes from the very first
man they're still happily married to
this day yes Corona was served at the
recession best fast and furious so of
all time you have the last word I'm
gonna be really boring five I think sort
of took it in a different new and
different direction the direction that I
love but seven was my favorite all right
so we got a vote for seven but for five
and a vote for the original and I think
we all voted fresh for Hobbs and Shaw
it's in theaters now so if you have not
already checked it out and you watch
this for review go see and then come
back comment right now let us know your
thoughts on Hobbs and Shaw was it the
best action you've seen in the franchise
do you love the rock and state them
together how about those cameos and
where do you want to see the franchise
go from here that's gonna do it for us
today on the after show make sure you
subscribe to the Rotten Tomatoes YouTube
channel and hit that Bell gonna give you
an alert every time we have a new after
show for y'all thanks to my incredible
panelists I'm merely Mark Ellis and
we'll see you all real soon here at the
after show
[Music]
you